hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday April 3rd 2017 with going on
Alaia how's it go the white guy Def Jam
voice little white bag Def Jam voice I
taking you back through a little comedy
history remember that the height of
black guys do those white guys do that
it was always a half half and half half
that [ __ ] voice you see a whack I
stayed in a chair oh [ __ ] the chair Oh I
mean a black guy when he sits the change
sits in the [ __ ] chair like I
said ah gee laughs it out actual I do my
taxes every [ __ ] joke
crushed [ __ ] crushed that was the
black comic version of white guys going
talking about flying on airplanes
comparing dogs two cats that's more like
it you know don't you Fred a cat or it
doesn't [ __ ] you know that's actually
still not complimentary voice for a
white guy but I don't think that was a
complimentary voice for a black guy so I
think I'm in the clear when it comes to
political correctness um oh my god what
a [ __ ] weekend I had man I had a
great time you know why I had a great
time I watched the [ __ ] Bruins pick up
four points this weekend all right and
put themselves back into the driver's
seat at least of their own destiny all
right by beating the Florida [ __ ]
Panthers and thank God the Chicago
Blackhawks had the decency to rest most
of the good guys in their team we really
pick up another two points so thank you
to the city of Chicago next deep-dish is
on me if I run into you not the whole
[ __ ] City just one of you fatties
what are you mustachioed fatties from
that SNL sketch I don't think I've ever
seen a guy with a mustache in Chicago
you know um anyways I never heard one
say duck bears never heard that never
heard it um although I don't talk to a
lot of them I just kind of go there and
stand in front of them performing and
then I leave that's basically what I do
which is one of my favorite things to
[ __ ] do by the way there's nothing
there's nothing better than when you do
your show the second you do it you get
a car and you get the [ __ ] out of there
that's my favorite thing to do you know
either that or go to a dive bar and hang
out like with three people that's the
way I'm [ __ ] why um that's perfect be
honest but there's a certain people they
like to hang out you know what I mean go
wade into the crowd you know continue
continue to say how awesome I am I don't
do that I got it for that hour perfect
then you get the car it's nice and quiet
it's quiet it just [ __ ] ride home you
know and you go into your [ __ ] hotel
room right sit down you avoid the
[ __ ] snack bar right and uh and then
that's it then you just sit there and
the loneliness of your room that's most
reason why I drink on the road to be
honest with you that's all you do it is
you just trying to stay out as long as
you can so you're so [ __ ] tired that
when you get back to your room you just
immediately fall asleep rather than
dealing with the [ __ ] loneliness of
it but I don't know I had such a great
weekend man I played a little bit of
drums hung out with my beautiful
daughter you know she's a riot she's
bossy as hell oh my god she's already
telling us what to do with just like the
noises that she knows how to make um
yeah she's gonna be a little smiley just
like my wife she's [ __ ] adorable as
hell obviously you know I'm a little
biased but uh that's kind of you know
you know when people are lying you know
if bought you kid
oh hey were cutie I feel like we're
getting like legit compliments so
anyways could anybody out there in the
hockey world explain to me like how this
like what seed you are works in the
playoff bracket like I don't get it
because it used to be like the Adams
division and the Patric division in one
played four and then they sort of
jumbled them all up it seems like when
they list them as far as like I don't
get when you go to the standings things
because I would have thought is as a
sixth or seventh see whatever the [ __ ]
gonna be we'd either play the Capitol's
or the Blue Jackets you know that the
top of that one but they're kind of
doing like a March Madness thing where
it's like we're like a different thing
so for some reason we get off easy or I
should say and have to play the Maple
Leafs rather than getting the old right
there Fred from the Capitals of the Blue
Jackets not saying that we're going to
be Toronto I have no idea what's going
to happen but according to the Stanley
Cup playoff here on on nhl.com as of
today the Montreal Canadiens with cloade
Julia Julian I would play [ __ ] the
New York Rangers so they're number one
seed and then they would get the wild
card New York Rangers and then the
Bruins would play the Maple Leafs a
little original six action there for you
on those both of those huh then the
Capitals would play Ottawa in Pittsburgh
plays Columbus like Pittsburgh gets
punished shouldn't they be playing an
easier [ __ ] team with the points they
have I would think what I'm the bottom
feeders so that's great I love that
Pittsburgh or the Columbus will knock
each other out well not one of the other
out I should say and I know I don't know
what's gonna go this is the Capitals
finally gonna push through this year is
it finally gonna happen you know you
know it'd be the [ __ ] Armageddon
finals would be the Washington Capitals
versus the San Jose Sharks you know can
one of them has to win right like the
Cubs versus the Indians somebody's got a
[ __ ] win and I bet it would go down
the exact same way one would go up three
two one you know they just got to add
that last bit of misery and then someone
would come back and win it I don't know
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about all I know is I really enjoyed
them obviously this weekend and if we
can play the Tampa Bay Lightning on
Tuesday and [ __ ] put them out of
their goddamn misery I think we would
avoid three years in a row of you know
eating a dick at the end of much at the
beginning of April we've done it two
years in a row so that's it that's it
for the [ __ ] hockey talk oh by the
way I don't know what his name is with
that kid on Calgary I keep to Chuck
his kid out there the kids a [ __ ]
riot man he's an old school hockey
player I was watching uh what do they
have there with the [ __ ] Don Cherry
Hockey Night in Canada we actually get
that down here and he was showing a
highlight of that kid you know picking
on that dude from the [ __ ] Kings Don
Cherry's breaking his [ __ ] balls and
it's just like they're trying to make
the playoffs he's not going to get
involved in some stupid [ __ ] fight
right
they drew doubting he they need him on
the ice I would think anyways drew
doubting the Dave Grohl of [ __ ] of
hockey to me that they're the exact same
[ __ ] person when Dave Grohl is not
making amazing music he's playing
defense for the Los Angeles Kings I
challenge you I challenge you to find
Dave Grohl ever at a [ __ ] game where
where Drew Doughty is not as a healthy
scratch um all right enough of that
[ __ ] I can't even talk to you about
my [ __ ] weekend some of this other
[ __ ] oh my god hung other we ever
hang out looks just like a complete
[ __ ] psychopath
ah it's one of those social events you
like oh no there he is there he is and
then it's over
and then it's the next day like up great
you know God willing I'll never have to
see that person again hey how the [ __ ]
of the Celtics the number one seat I
didn't watch in the last two weeks I
kind of got you know you know with
[ __ ] hockey and basketball you kind
of got like a pic of sport you know I've
been you know I've been trying to watch
both of them but um the Bruins were just
in a more you know I don't know
precarious position so it was more of a
exciting thing to watch are they going
to [ __ ] this up are they going to
somehow pull themselves out of it and
somehow the Celtics or number one seed
although I don't think they're a better
team than the Cavaliers but I like what
LeBron did the other night last night
when he got into it on the court and
that made that other dude on his own
team flipping out yelling at him and
[ __ ] he immediately tried to defuse it
and then was just saying yeah I showed
him up I should have said that blah blah
blah and I was like that
again later right there even though a
lot of people don't like him I [ __ ]
like LeBron um so anyways dude I've just
been having like I know I got to get
back into [ __ ] meditating I don't
know I just keep running into these
situations like I feel like I'm
attracting that to me like somebody's
this New York number has been calling me
for like the last [ __ ] three days and
then I'm like I don't know who this
number is so I don't answer and then
they finally leave a message and say
yeah he's showing show you know I'm
looking for so-and-so but it keeps
saying uh you know this is Bill uh on
the thing but my phone is saying you
know it's my daughter
so I'm like alright well this guy's
gonna figure this [ __ ] out right and he
doesn't so he filed right before he did
the podcast he [ __ ] calls again so I
finally picked up I go hello guys I
guess I was just [ __ ] I'm talking to I'm
like well it's not who you think it is
yeah you got the wrong number and he
goes yeah well [ __ ] you too he hangs up
on me like like it was my fault
so I just laugh and I'm just like what
the [ __ ] why does this [ __ ] keep
happening to me so then he calls back
and I'm like boy I got to hear what this
guy's gonna say next right I need a new
hour of material I got to put myself in
the line of fire here so I picked up it
goes yeah man I'm sorry man I just I
lost my phone and I keep trying to call
my daughter and you know my name's bill
and it keeps saying your name's bill and
it's you got to see the humor in that
right I'm like yeah man it's said say
yeah it's a funny situation good luck to
you your phone I don't I don't know what
to tell you it sounded like a nice
enough person I love that he said yeah
well [ __ ] you too and he still had the
[ __ ] nerve to call me back and then
just say act like it didn't he didn't
say that maybe was just joking when he
said it I just saying I don't [ __ ]
know so anyways this past week so I'm at
this social event I'm trying to avoid
this psycho and he ends up sitting right
next to me and I'm talking this guy for
[ __ ] ten minutes all of a sudden I
can't find my cell phone and I'm looking
for it and I'm looking for it and I'm
not bringing
up to anybody because I'm thinking like
maybe I left in a car I don't know what
and I realized that this psycho has
placed his cell phone
exactly right on top of mine on the
table like completely lined up in mine
has a black case it was kind of dark so
I couldn't see it and then I had to sit
there playing this [ __ ] mind game
like did this guy do this on purpose am
i over analyzing this thing am I out of
my [ __ ] mind and I don't know that it
the whole thing just struck me as funny
thinking of how my life used to be
because I used to have people like that
in my [ __ ] life you know those people
that mind [ __ ] you and then like an hour
later hey that [ __ ] wife beater
relationship you got to get into ah yeah
which is course how the evening ends
with that [ __ ] I add in me and I
it's alright everything's cool and I
just walked out of there and just felt
like this [ __ ] weight lifts off me
just be like I'm never gonna see that
person again I have no [ __ ] desire
that is it that is a [ __ ] wrap if I
have learned anything from hanging out
with [ __ ] a a cup I have two good
friends of mine that are both half
Sicilian and when applied correctly the
Sicilian you're dead to me when applied
correctly is the greatest [ __ ] it
just streamlines your life why would you
waste another second of your life
playing that mental tennis with
something like you obviously don't
connect with this person over and you
just walk away and then that's it and
like today I just woke up I was in the
greatest [ __ ] mood knowing I'm never
gonna see that person again
it's [ __ ] tremendous and you know
what I think then I created a void I
created a vacuum in my life because I
just let go all of that [ __ ] and now I
got this random guy calling me up on my
cell phone looking for his daughter and
then telling me to go [ __ ] myself you
know I'll take that I mean that's
easy one that guy actually sounded like
a better [ __ ] person so anyways oh
you know what Easter's coming up [ __ ]
easter it comes Peter Cottontail hop it
dad buddy trail hippity-hoppity Easter's
on its way um I uh I get this week we're
gonna actually at some point we're gonna
go back to the mall I've become a
[ __ ] mall person I imagine eventually
it's going to uh it's going to drive me
nuts but we're going there we're taking
our daughter over to get a picture with
the Easter Bunny how [ __ ] cute is that
it's gonna be absolutely adorable I
can't wait to do it so we just have to
calve out some time um and I'm already
nervous that she's gonna get totally
[ __ ] freaked out you don't I mean if
the older you get the more you look at
that you just realize why what is that
bizarre ritual you know why would you do
that - sorry my stomach's grumbling yeah
I'm [ __ ] on a massive diet here
massive diet massive die cutting out the
booze except the last night cutting out
the booze been eating basically
perfectly and I'm actually down to a
buck 79 my fight weights between like
168 172 and I'm sure going to try to
lose two or three pounds for them you
know I figured some by mid-may mid-may I
ought to be in fighting shape and uh but
if I to actually stay in that and
continue because what out you know what
I do is I get down to the way I wanted
to get down to and then that's like the
end of the movie roll credits and I go
back to eating [ __ ] pizza beer and
all of that [ __ ] and then I slowly get
back up again and next thing you know
I'm standing shirtless in a mirror just
calling myself every horrible name and
the that I can think of you know top of
[ __ ] something I've never even heard
anybody say I actually called myself
that before I started this diet I
actually have suits that I can't fit
into any more like I've hit that point
in my life and it's just like I can't I
can't I can't be the guy that goes to
the [ __ ] dry cleaner to have his
suits
let out you go to the tailor and you're
just basically saying listen the food 1
I quit I quit I don't want to [ __ ] do
this anymore
so um anyways I did uh I just been doing
I just been doing cardio my [ __ ]
shoulders getting better I can't really
lift weights or anything so I've just
been kind of just stretching doing
cardio in and trying to eat right I try
to eat like from 9:00 to 5:00 and then
just stop but the other night I was
doing that uh April foolishness for
Kevin of bean who I want to thank for
having me on that we did it down at the
the Shrine Auditorium which is a famous
theater out here what the [ __ ] going
on my brain it came and think here I
actually went on Wikipedia that's what
happens I was trying to look at some of
this other shits in this advertising I
have to read I literally get like
anxiety as I look at it like ah I look
along as [ __ ] coffee is I don't want
to read all that as I'm trying to talk
to you guys my apologies I was
distracted there so I played the Shrine
Auditorium for Kevin it being Show April
foolishness every year that raises money
for I think it's premature babies I
believe that's what it is I never know
what it is I always ask right before I
go on what is this cause for so I can
steer clear of going out there like
what's up with premature babies should I
just let it die or something you know
just not walking into that so we're at
the Shrine Auditorium and I look went up
on Wikipedia went up I went to it on on
the internet there and I found out that
that is the place the most legendary
thing that I saw that happened at that
place aside from like the Grateful Dead
and all these guys doing shows was that
was the place where Michael Jackson shot
the Pepsi commercial and had his hair
lit on fire
his jheri curl you know when he was
slowly at the beginning was the
beginnings of transforming into a white
guy you know I don't know what if it was
the the product he had if it was a jheri
curl if it was a conk I don't know what
he had going on okay I don't know how
that mixes with Pepsi and flammable [ __ ]
but all I know is his head lit on fire
and he got second-degree burns that was
it and I'll
all these [ __ ] people work like
crying they were terrified you know that
this tremendous artist his head caught
on fire his [ __ ] head caught on fire
doing a a Pepsi commercial
there was another groundbreaking thing
that he did like because back in the day
if you were a any sort of a famous
person and if you did a commercial you
were just considered a complete sellout
at least in the white world I don't know
how it worked
he kinda was a hybrid though he sort of
the first Caitlyn Jenner but he did it
like in a race way you know like the way
he walked out the door dude and came
back a woman he walked out the door
black guy it came back a white guy um I
mean I can't imagine being friends with
that guy every time he would leave you
didn't just come back he was like a
Shopaholic but like for his face you
know what I mean his chicks always
coming about with coming back with like
a new bag you don't I mean or some
[ __ ] I don't know what shoes or some
[ __ ] he would do the same thing but with
his face yeah bill he was one of most
famous people ever we know what he did
okay anyways plowing ahead so I got to
do that show down at the Shrine
Auditorium and I cannot even begin to
tell you what a [ __ ] great time I had
unbelievable crowd like I to do a half
hour at the end of all these other
monsters going out there [ __ ] killing
it the entire night and steve-o did a
hilarious [ __ ] stunt [ __ ]
hilarious
and I got to go on like at the end of
all this [ __ ] and do a half hour and it
was [ __ ] effortless that's how great
the crowd was so I want to thank
everybody who came out for that
wonderful cause that I believe was for
premature kids you guys like the birds
chirping in the background somebody
mentioned to me that's [ __ ] hilarious
listen to be going off on [ __ ] with
birds chirping I usually don't do uh do
my [ __ ] podcast in this room I just
do it cuz it's the furthest one away
from my daughter is sleeping you know
I'd want to hear me dropping all the
f-bombs so anyways the end of the show
comes right everybody shaking hands oh
you were great now you
great no I like how your mind works no I
like how your mind works better you know
we're all doing the Hollywood thing
right everybody had a good set and once
again I ran into one of these crazy
[ __ ] parents right
this is [ __ ] hilarious this is what
this person did they said Oh
congratulations on your daughter I said
oh you brought it up you brought it up
now I got to show you a picture right so
her husband is standing there right the
young young people right they look like
this single they don't even look like
they have kids and I just show him the
picture and she just goes oh yeah it's
so easy you see it's so easy it's so
easy
she started pointing my kid going it's
so easy like what the [ __ ] is she
talking about I've heard she's adorable
she's cute oh my God look at those
cheeks she's God so it's so yeah see you
see it's so easy I'm like what do you
mean it's so easy she goes she goes we
have three we have three it's so hard
you have no idea so and just she used my
daughter's picture as a way to launch it
that how [ __ ] difficult her life was
first was like how [ __ ] difficult is
your life the two you look like you've
been p90x in need you guys don't have an
ounce of fat on you you don't have bags
under your eyes it's Saturday night
you're out at a show neither one of you
yawning and they were going yeah we had
one and then and then we got pregnant
again and we had we had and I was going
like oh yeah and I'm sitting trying to
be empathetic oh yeah you know I hear uh
I hear two is like a game-changer and
then three it's like you're outnumbered
she goes oh no we went from one right to
three like we had we had we had twins
next and with two kids we'll I don't
even know what that feels like we don't
even know what that feels like it's just
like you know what you don't know what
if you don't know it's like to be in a
[ __ ] log cabin with no [ __ ] heat
like they had 20 years ago it's [ __ ]
hard the [ __ ] out of here I swear to God
like people like that it's just I just
feel bad for their kids it's like you
have to be you got to be a [ __ ]
terrible parent what kind of person has
a kid right and and all I do when I see
other people
kids is I just think of how much that
person must love that kid they have to
feel the same way that I do about my kid
and then I'm happy for who the [ __ ]
looks at somebody else's kid just and
compares like oh it's so it's so easy
yeah see it's easy and then I go yeah
you know what we're thinking to having
another one and then then the guy goes
yeah I just have one don't have to war
first of all like you can control it uh
they drive me up the [ __ ] wall
I [ __ ] I'm gonna say it I [ __ ]
hate parents generally speaking I cannot
stand them they like they're like
[ __ ] martyrs they're like these
[ __ ] he's like you put yourself in
this situation shut the [ __ ] up you have
three people that are gonna be sad when
you die they're actually gonna give a
[ __ ] and they're going to show up and
say how great you are it were it isn't
that enough it's so hard
you have no L really with iPads in
[ __ ] 200 channels of cable you can
put them in front of a [ __ ] plasma TV
it's like looking into a tropical fish
tank all day for ya this soft you know I
mean I don't I guess oh god there's so
many times in my life like I wish I
could just go back like that I'm doing
you believe it or not I'm great in the
moment on stage I'm so bad at it when
I'm off stage you know what I mean I'm
just you know cuz I immediately just get
to this anger level then I end up
looking like a psycho like I wish I just
said that to him like you guys sound
like terrible parents do you want to put
your kids up for adoption so maybe you
can go back to doing blow or whatever
the [ __ ] it is that you miss do patacon
wish i could go back to last night and
just tap that guy on his shoulder and
just pointed his cellphone on top of
mine and just be like it on a
psychological level would you like to
explain this to me how did this happen
was this by accident but I don't I don't
[ __ ] say anything and then I just
[ __ ] write people off and then they
look at me like I'm out of my mind which
I am I'm definitely out of my mind but
I'll tell you right now I'm not the only
one I am not the only one and I have
learned that I learned that this weekend
so UST it's so easy it's so it's like
why would you say you don't have any
[ __ ] idea imagine had a special-needs
kid then you pointed it saying it's so
easy what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh that's right you're completely
self-involved ah ah felt good to get
this out oh Jesus I'm glad I didn't say
I'm glad I saved it for the podcast but
wouldn't the podcast be better if I
actually started saying these things to
people so that I would have the
confrontations and I could just maybe I
could then do a two-hour podcast
hey who knows who knows so you know I as
I mentioned earlier or the last podcast
I got um I finally got Sirius satellite
radio on my car so I'm [ __ ] listening
to the 80s channel the seventies Channel
NHL you know I listen to Opie show Jim
Norton's [ __ ] show and I finally
listen to Howard Stern for the first
time in [ __ ] forever and he had Craig
Ferguson on and Craig Ferguson was going
on and on about the Chappelle [ __ ]
special I got to check it out he was
going on and on it might be the Craig
that's one I've ever seen I'm like oh
[ __ ] I gotta check that out I gotta
[ __ ] check that one out but half of
me does not want to watch it because I
know it's going to be I don't to feel
like oh my god uh certain people you
watch to get inspired I can't watch his
[ __ ] cuz I make out god I suck really
the gap is still that large you know I
don't know everyone's you know every
once in a while you think you're [ __ ]
Hendrix and then you realize you just
playing a ukulele right isn't that what
happens isn't that what life is um
anyways let me live it sweet a little
bit of the advertising here uh it's
unbelievable it's a great especially
I've ever seen I was just like Jesus
Christ
alright ProFlowers everybody uh have you
ever forgotten your anniversary uh yeah
to be honest with you right now I I
would if you asked me I would be M
eighty percent sure of my anniversary
date but fortunately I married a person
who also we don't we can never we don't
really remember the day that we met we
don't have a Dave
that and we like this year we were just
like what's what's our wedding date
again see lemons right
no 12 no 11 11 11 yeah it's 11 but if I
don't know if you married some I don't
know accountants if you married an
insecure account they know what the date
is right have you ever forgotten your
anniversary if you're nodding yes you're
lying
really I didn't figure that you know
those people that are just hard to shop
for wait what the [ __ ] stay if you have
you ever forgotten your anniversary if
you're nodding yes you're lying
well I wasn't nodding but I have I've
actually booked myself on my anniversary
weekend because I forgot I just don't
think that I just think Oh every other
week I go on the road and if it lands on
that week then I wasn't out and it just
you know I don't any ProFlowers said
Jesus are they [ __ ] psychos are they
going to put this cell phone on top of
my cell phone anyways you know those
people that are just hard to shop for
like your wife for your anniversary or
your sister for her birthday it's just
the worst trying to fit trying to find a
gift that that a you know they'll like
and be won't cost an arm and a leg all
right first of all that's what the [ __ ]
they want they want something that
they're going to like and they also want
something that's going to cost an arm
and a leg ProFlowers stop acting like
this is like a substitute for a gift all
right you are the [ __ ] appetizer this
is a great appetizer getting flowers but
if you think you get a [ __ ] every
year just get your wife flowers
hey Tut's thanks for hanging in there
nursing the baby when you shove these in
your face and give him a whiff I'm going
to throw them in a vase they'll be dead
in two days this cost me 29 bucks that's
how I feel for you this is what you get
for as a nap cool throw ball to whatever
the [ __ ] else you're gonna get right a
condiment this is the mustard on top of
the hotdog that costs like [ __ ] you
know whatever it is you make like a good
40 percent of your cell salary alright
celery salary alright
well I'm gonna make it easy few
ProFlowers is my go-to for flowers it
isn't there's a guy down the street that
sells them he puts them together great
it's a person and I like them but you
know if I'm sitting in a cubicle and out
of time for this [ __ ] I'm going to
ProFlowers alright they're fresh priced
right in our perfo the perfect gift for
literally anyone and yeah get one for
one of your buddies I'm sure I'll love
them and they get delivered straight to
your recipients door how easy is that
and that's what women don't like he
didn't put any [ __ ] thought in this
whatsoever that's why it's a nickel drum
all right now ProFlowers has a special
offer for just our listeners get $10 off
your purchase of $29 or more Pro flower
bouquets or bouquets police or police
are guaranteed fresh for seven days or
your money back
they have a seven-step quality check
which means the flowers are always
awesome their website is super easy to
use you can schedule your delivery ahead
of time for any date you want and get
back get back to yellow [ __ ] day Pro
flowers is a no-brainer gift for a
birthday which is why you have to get it
also get er something else an
anniversary every occasion
or even for no occasion at all any time
when you want her to feel special they
take care of all the details ya
ProFlowers is great for date if your
going to add it to a gift or if it's not
a special day and you just get it form
that's a [ __ ] great thing you know
like if there's seven days out of the
year you know [ __ ] their birthday
your anniversary Valentine's Day that
[ __ ] bird in the tree
flag day okay this is when you get get
around like [ __ ] you know July 18th I
was just thinking you those [ __ ]
birds are crazy huh anyways I know you
have either a birthday or your
anniversary coming up so right now get
$10 off your purchase of 29 29 dollars
or more at ProFlowers but this deal
definitely will not last long just go to
proflowers.com and enter code BIR at
checkout to get this special deal all
right there you go oh look who's me on
DS but up Bulbul me on DS
me undies get you broad some [ __ ]
flowers doo-doo-doo-doo me undies me
undies wash your balls in the showers
they'll spell really nice rub the roses
on them she'll [ __ ] come over and say
why did you do that why did you squat in
the [ __ ] vase so cuz I'm I want to
sit on your face with my me undies sorry
that one was all over the place elevate
your underwear game to the next level
with me undies your partner you
perfected your wardrobe but what about
the stuff not everybody gets to see if
you've been settling for store-bought
underwear five packs I have something
that will change your life for the
better me undies what's the first thing
you put on and the last thing you take
off we all know what you had but this
isn't about that
it's your underwear make your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies what is me undies
you might be asking at your cubicle oh
just seriously soft feel-good undies
delivered right to your [ __ ] door
the undies are designed in Los Angeles
or Louisiana I have no idea LA and made
from sustainably sustainably sourced
micro modal Modell a fabric three times
softer than cotton and if you're not
ready for it it's [ __ ] hilarious your
balls are going to be so [ __ ]
cushioned right compared to the callous
hands I'm kidding
they're made here by union workers and
if you're not ready for a subscription
that's okay hey no pressure you can
still save that's because my undies is
offering you 20% off your first pair
just use our special URL me undies
dot-com slash four and get 20% off your
first pair so go ahead revamp your
underwear drawer you deserve it once
again that's my undies com / / me undies
calm / / and we got two more and these
are quick reads and I love it alright do
only shade Club do buying a [ __ ]
raise is like buying a cat to smoke get
to get smooth luxury quality you have to
pay a huge price and that means you pay
it mostly for splashy marketing features
you don't actually need switch to
dollarshaveclub.com everybody it's a
smarter choice luxury quality and an
economy Price Dollar Shave club's raises
are amazing quality they've got the
shave tech you need and none of the
overpriced gimmicky [ __ ] you don't
alright
have you seen they add for the razor's
monopolies newest razor thing it has
like 21 blades swivel pivot [ __ ]
robot razor with a laser pointer to your
chin every year they make it tiny
changes arranging they do that they
change it a little bit and then the new
[ __ ] blades don't fit it and then you
got to keep up with the Joneses it's
complete boys [ __ ] all right you
want to get out of it joint Dollar Shave
Club and be done with all of that [ __ ]
there's never been a better time to give
them a shot right now you can get your
first month of any of their amazing
razors for only a buck including free
shipping and after that it's just a few
bucks a month there's no long term
commitment no hidden fees and you can
cancel whenever the [ __ ] you want
get your first month for just a buck at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com and lastly but not
leastly stamps.com you know what I use
stamps com whenever I'm sending out any
of my posters when I feel like I'm gonna
[ __ ] myself out at the end of the shows
trying to just wring every last dollar
out of my [ __ ] fan base all right I'm
a [ __ ] if I can figure out how to use
their [ __ ] scale and stamp machine so
can you stamps saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
I can mail any letter any package using
my just my computer and printer and the
mailman comes and picks it up avoid the
hassle man of the post office and mail
everything from postcards to stamps to
envelopes re to packages domestics or
international stamps com will even help
you decide the best class of mail based
on your needs no need to leased an
expense an expensive postage meter right
now you can enjoy the stamps service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bur that stamps
comm enter ber stamps com never go to
the post
this again alright anyways hey how about
the [ __ ] the Patriots might be
talking up to Adrian Peterson huh if
you're a [ __ ] I don't know if even
watching the Patriots for a long time
doesn't that remind you when we signed
Corey Dillon that'd be nice to get that
[ __ ] guy wouldn't maybe see Tom Brady
get number six right Tommy said he said
he wanted to play for another five or
six years that's [ __ ] unbelievable
just the fact that he's gonna do that
means he's gonna play for at least
another three so he gets a legitimate
shot at gettin another ring unreal
unreal good lord I [ __ ] enjoy that
alright because every time every replays
I always think this could be the last
year it could be the last [ __ ] year
you know Belichick is almost 70 years
old Brady's gonna be 40 you know and you
know
oh we're gonna [ __ ] what's going to
happen on that franchise when those two
people leave who knows because
what's-his-face Robert Kraft he's three
coaching hires Bill Parcells Pete
Carroll Bill Belichick he's three for
three
alright let's read some of these uh some
of these emails for the week girl freaks
out hey there Billy Boy George um it was
funny I never liked him and when I was
in the in the 80s you know it's too
homophobic to like that guy but uh his
[ __ ] drummers to [ __ ] on that do you
really wanna be loved the [ __ ] drums
on that song anyways not sure if you saw
this yet some girl freaked out at a
yogurt shop in Santa Monica because the
couple behind her kissed each other she
starts saying that she was being
sexually harassed by them doing so it
gets out of control
the funny thing is that she starts off
acting like a hacky liberal but then
ends acting like a hacky conservatives
as she shifted through stages of emotion
the Phoenix video tour video look great
can't wait for San Jose yeah I actually
I watched some of that at first I love
this
woman because I hate people who [ __ ] I
don't hate I hate looking at people
making out in public it's [ __ ] gross
it's [ __ ] gross you tongue jam down
each other's throats you know it's like
he I don't wanna look especially when
I'm around food I totally get what she's
saying but then she took it too far when
she started saying that she was uh that
she was being sexually harassed what I
did love though is I love how the
extreme close-up when she's yelling into
the camera it reminded me of that movie
misery you know with it ladies like you
can't do whatever the [ __ ] she says was
there anything more satisfying in a
[ __ ] movie when he finally got to the
bed and started slamming that bitch's
head against the floor ah just laying
there that powerless do you know in the
book she actually cuts his feet off
rather than breaking his goddamn ankles
um I gotta be honest with you I really
think I could have sweet-talked my way
out of that bed I really would have I
would act like I wanted to [ __ ] her you
know I would have done that right yeah I
would have told her that I was never
gonna leave her I would have built her
[ __ ] up until I started to be able to
walk around right and then I would
actually and once I could even was help
this is how long of a slow play I would
go with that woman I would actually I
would after I could walk I would stay in
a three-month relationship with her till
she got so [ __ ] comfortable right and
then one day I'd be making my famous
[ __ ] scrambled eggs take out a
[ __ ] skillet that would be it man I
would I would stay in a relationship
with that woman until the [ __ ] snow
melted you know and I could shake off
whatever thing I had they have [ __ ]
or I could shake that off I'm German
Irish I can [ __ ] I could put that in
a box and never think of it again
no pun intended that's what I would have
done he [ __ ] up you know what I mean
he actually wrote the real [ __ ] book
I guess I that's because I know that she
was out of her mind but I swear to God I
would have [ __ ] I would have told her
that I loved what she did with her hair
all of that thing the hardest thing
would have been was not laughing
noises that she would have made during
intersex intersex intercourse intersex
um anyways I don't know what that says
about me but you know I bet that's how
what I got out of it I would have just
gone totally like ah yeah yeah is she
beautiful oh my god this soup is [ __ ]
delicious and I would have just talked
to her and just find out what the exact
[ __ ] book she wanted me to write and
that's exactly what I would have written
maybe I hit her with a typewriter like
some sort of symbolism no but at the end
of the day you know [ __ ] some pig
versus getting both of your [ __ ]
ankles broken I mean I I don't think
there's a there's really no trade-off
right um you probably won't eat she's
such a [ __ ] lunatic she's probably
like a sexual you probably only have to
do that you know just laugh at her jokes
I think you would have been alright um
anyway so I just went on a tangent there
sorry about that uh here we go girl so
anyways getting back to that yeah I
don't like when uh I don't like watching
people make out it's [ __ ] gross me I
hated him but the two things I hate most
in movies is when people are [ __ ]
making out and and people when they're
eating in the scene and they're [ __ ]
making those [ __ ] noises there's
nothing worse than watching an actor eat
in a scene because most times they're
not eating so they have to overact
eating and everybody I don't know what
happens they turn into [ __ ] animals
they started eating with their mouths
open they start pointing at people with
the bread that and I I hate love scenes
in movies you don't I mean like when
they take it to the point where
literally one actor is sucking on the
other actress titties it's just like I
get it they're gonna have sex like what
are you gonna take it to this level are
you making a porno no I want to watch a
porno I'll just watch a [ __ ] porno
why can't you just have walk in the
bedroom and then they close the door I
get it they [ __ ] like who is that for
take my breath away
they're always up against a wall and
it's [ __ ] raining out or some [ __ ]
you know to me rather than they're
getting used to each other
figuring out which lip to go for do you
go for the top lip for the bottom lip
you know what I mean what position do
you like do you like to have your ass
slapped or not
now that shits out of the way they just
automatically start acting like they've
been banging each other the whole summer
little bit golden whatever [ __ ] songs
they play what are some of the stupid
the 80s they always played that stupid
saxophone the saxophone got ruined in
the 80s it went from this like it went
literally from this instrument that when
it was in the hands of a black person it
actually scared the CIA to the 80s where
it just meant that Tom Cruise was going
to [ __ ] somebody you know half of those
jazz guys in the [ __ ] from the 40s
50s and 60s they had their [ __ ]
phones bugged by the goddamn J Edgar
Hoover and the FBI and then this it's
just somehow it just all went to [ __ ] in
the 70s it all went to [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] 70s you know they whacked
everybody that they needed to whack in
the 60s they figured out how not to lose
public support of a war after the
debacle of Vietnam right so now they got
everybody everybody's alive what troops
are you four five what proof I for
everything I said who doesn't support
the troops they're on our team but the
brilliance is they've now morph that
into you cannot criticize the war if you
do or anything that the Pentagon is
doing because now you're criticizing
some 18 year old is over there fighting
for your freedom it's [ __ ] brilliant
but we should have seen this coming with
what happened to the saxophone in the
eighties all right girlfriend says I'm
stagnant oh Jesus oh dude that's a major
red flag uh hey Bill you Tiny Tim
looking red-nosed peckerhead okay who is
Tiny Tim again Oh tiny tips an ugly
[ __ ] with the ukulele
Jesus Christ Wow he looks like if
somebody beat the [ __ ] out of George
Washington thank you wow that one really
hurt uh anyways uh maybe I'll pull a
Michael Jackson get a cleft in my chin
love you love your podcast but you wrote
you love your podcast even though I
never get any advice will you give me
some I have L this is somebody who's not
going to use any punctuation this is all
one sentence loved you Pato maybe this
person's foreign loved you podcast even
though I never get any advice will you
give me some advice will you give me
some I have this girlfriend I really
like that's all one sentence we work
together at the local restaurant I was
fine until I got fired then I got into a
fight with my girlfriend's sister's
boyfriend got that no I don't all right
I mean let me try to break this down
here all right
you have this girlfriend you really like
we work together at the local restaurant
I guess everything was cool and then you
got fired and then you got into a fight
with her with hers her sister her
sister's boyfriend okay so your
girlfriend at work you got into a fight
with her sister's boyfriend and then you
got fired from the TGI Fridays whatever
the [ __ ] he did all right I'm back on
board then I got a DWA I driving while
alcohol influenced I don't know what I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on here
um and I feel like a complete loser and
sometimes it gets me depressed also I
still give her rides to work which she
tells me means nothing and also says she
loves me but has been getting meaner
every day I don't get a job all right
well okay well in defense of her you
have to understand what the woman that
if you're not bringing in money you just
literally have your like a 40 year old
teenager at that point you're just like
a big kid she has to deal with um you
know in women they're all feminists
until they have to start paying for
everything you don't I mean
like what's [ __ ] up with sexism and
all that and that guys have better
paying jobs evidently I have no idea
I've never asked people what the [ __ ]
they make but let's just say what
they're saying is true what's [ __ ] up
is is it now created this thing where
women can date and like you're always
for the most part dating up you know if
you're if you have reasonable [ __ ]
looks okay
and you had a reasonably good childhood
and for whatever you're not migrating
towards [ __ ] losers alright you can
actually always be in a situation where
getting married is a good thing because
the other person makes more money than
you so you if the whole [ __ ] thing
falls apart you're going to get the
house you're going to get the child
support you're going to get the alimony
right only lately are we finally
starting to see women having to do that
and it's [ __ ] a little Ike they freak
the [ __ ] out like what right a woman
paid alimony was it like I all of a
sudden got my period
and like wait I got to do this now what
the [ __ ] right um anyway so anyways let
me get back to the [ __ ] thing here I
keep I keep going on tangents here I
need to stay focused um so okay so you
got a DUI right and she still gives me a
[ __ ] okay so now you're not making any
money so you know then you're all
depressed and you don't have a G car so
I'm guessing you're not really looking
for a [ __ ] job or maybe she's just
meaning [ __ ] I don't know anyways he
said I've never had trouble getting work
when I needed it but now I feel like a
lazy piece of [ __ ] my girlfriend called
me stagnant stagnant and told me she's
worried she said tonight she would see
me later then change it to or talk to
you later and trailed off muttering some
inaudible [ __ ] I need to pay my rent
tomorrow and I basically broke his [ __ ]
I gave her a key to my place and she
agreed to pay half the rent but I feel
like I'm twisting her arm to do it yeah
dude what are you doing I feel stagnant
too and depressed and she makes it hard
to think sometimes so I secretly bought
a train ticket to California
so I secretly bought a train ticket to
California from New York that leaves in
two weeks
I'm debating whether to stay here keep
looking for a job in a dead economy try
and work things out with my girl I'm
sorry guys like this is not me here this
is how this is written and faced in
music by paying thousands of fines and
traffic tickets while I'm broke as [ __ ]
or go with a couple a hippie friends
hike through through like he threw a
ball the state of California while
stopping to work on wolfing farms in
between journeys it's like Jack Kerouac
[ __ ]
I don't start to think this isn't real
to stay or to go I don't know but if she
calls me stagnant again I'll be out and
over the horizon I feel bad and I don't
know what the [ __ ] to do so any advice
is appreciated thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah first of all all right
let's just eliminate the woman from all
of this okay uh you need to pay your
traffic tickets dude if you think you're
just gonna walk away from that you're
gonna end up doing jail time a buddy of
mine did that okay and they put him in
County which you don't want to be in
because that's all different levels of
[ __ ] people's least in LA that's like
rapists lunatics like their own kid on
fire right down to yeah I had a bunch of
traffic tickets in it it got to such a
moment traffic ticket in a traffic
ticket
he had a DUI and he he didn't show up to
court maybe you won't go to jail I don't
know but it's it's gonna be a [ __ ]
nightmare this could be hanging over
your head and then you're gonna have to
try to work under the table which is
going to cause you not to [ __ ] pay
taxes it's going to be a nightmare so um
I don't know I would uh I would reach
out for help
is what I would do and it doesn't sound
like your girlfriend wants to do it
anymore you haven't told me how long
you've been unemployed but it sounds
like she's at the brink of being fed up
with you but uh you did get into a fight
you did get fired you did drink and
drive so you're making a bunch of bad
moves and it's not her fault that she's
trying to envision a future with you and
all she's saying is
she's gonna work while you're boozing it
up and she has to support you and I'm
gonna go out on a limb here I don't like
speaking for the ladies but I'm gonna go
out on a limb and say I don't think a
lot of women are looking for that in the
future so I would man up you need to man
the [ __ ] up and realize that you are
stagnant you need to get your [ __ ]
together all right I don't know what you
have to do to find a [ __ ] job that's
a difficult thing but I don't know can
you ask your parents for some help maybe
you [ __ ] leave your apartment move
back in with your parents while you get
through this you bottomed the [ __ ] out
you sober up you start working out with
the old weights you left in your parents
garage you find a [ __ ] job alright
get on a payment plan with your [ __ ]
tickets and all of that [ __ ] get all of
that off the table maybe even break up
with your girlfriend get your [ __ ]
together create a whole new [ __ ] you
and maybe you get a new girlfriend
that's beyond the level this one here
that was working at the [ __ ]
restaurant or whatever the hell you were
at alright but just know this you sound
like you're still young you got your
whole life ahead of you and you know you
know what you're doing is you're giving
in to your situation rather than [ __ ]
picking yourself up off the mat alright
to get up off the floor stop feeling
sorry for yourself
alright you have all the power in the
world to turn that thing around alright
and that's it get a job pay off your
tickets and you know see what happens
with that woman you know maybe she's not
the one maybe she is who knows but gives
a [ __ ] but work on your life work on
yourself there you go alright
girlfriends ultimatum help Jesus Christ
here we go again hey Billy bong my
girlfriend parentheses of over one year
recently gave me an ultimatum weed or
her
I chose weed alright there's a person
who knows what he likes did you say that
did you say that in the moment did you
wait a few days
did you Mull it over for a least a few
minutes sick of your pot smoking okay
and I know that you know I said earlier
that I was okay with it but the truth is
I'm not you're high all the time I think
it's affecting you and it's just I I'm
to the point I can't do this any
more so you need to make a choice either
you choose me or you choose marijuana
what's it gonna be I'm gonna choose the
weed sweetheart say she's gonna slowly
walk there head down out the [ __ ]
door it couldn't have gone down like
that anyways however as I perceived it
there was a choice of Reason versus
absurdity not her verse we'd allow me to
defend myself absolutely sir you have
the floor or our man you know this might
be a lesbian relationship my girl and I
started smoking together about two
months ago she was never big on it but I
was a self-admitted pothead in the past
we started smoking a couple months ago
at her request we would smoke one or two
hits per night before bed well last
night she decided that she didn't like
smoking weed anymore because she doesn't
like the feeling of being high
apparently in that same moment she
became morally opposed to the idea of
marijuana and she proceeded to call me
an addict that has a serious problem in
a grand dramatic gesture she flushed my
remaining weed down the toilet it made
me choose her or weed Wow that escalated
as they say in anchorman she kept
pointing at me in LA yelling look at
yourself you're so high right now keep
in mind I took one hit out of a
one-hitter
I called [ __ ] on all of her
arguments because as long as I've known
her she has never had a problem with
weed and would often encourage me to use
it because it does reduce my anxiety and
temper she often brags about her
ex-boyfriend selling weed and her
ex-husband smoking every day and it not
being an issue all right I was kind of
hearing her argument to those last
[ __ ] two sentences well this person
this this is a [ __ ] retread you're
with huh Jesus he got her out of the
recycle bin there
ayuh so I assumed this wasn't about weed
but something else I assume it's the
result of me telling her months ago oh
here we go that I wouldn't be with her
if she continued to drink because she
had a serious seriously unhealthy
relationship with alcohol
so I imagine she's trying to use this as
her chance to play holier-than-thou card
for the record I don't want to smoke
weed all day slash every day it's the
principle of the thing but now my
relationship is riding on this thing and
I don't want I don't want to do what is
riding on this thing and I don't want to
do
I think it's riding on this thing that
you don't want to do is think what
you're trying to say what are your
thoughts help her brother Rob
do I want to deal with this crazy level
of hypocrisy forever thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself I don't think so no I don't
think so
and they detach the way that you're able
to talk about her and you never once
said that you know I really love her
though you never said that so it sounds
like she had a rough childhood that led
into alcohol abuse and to her picking
some really [ __ ] so we're winners
here drug dealers and [ __ ] no Mike I
don't know what her ex-husband did but
he smoked every day yeah I I think the
way you tell it it doesn't sound like a
rational person so on the other side I
will tell you there are a lot of people
that's get high every day and don't
think that they have a problem whereas
if you get drunk every day people call
you a drunk and say you know you have a
problem I have a couple friends of mine
that did that for a good 20 [ __ ]
years and they paid the price smoking
weed every single [ __ ] day it's like
everything you wouldn't want to eat ice
cream every day you'd be a fat [ __ ]
drink booze every day you're gonna have
a bad liver gallbladder gin blossoming
[ __ ] alcohol is brutal and I actually
you know now that I've finally been
educated a little bit on weed I really
do believe it's way way worse it
definitely ages you way way way more
than we does but I don't think like you
no wake-and-bake people and people need
weed to fall asleep I know it helps with
anxiety and [ __ ] like that and obviously
you know pain of chemotherapy it's got a
lot of great things but I I when it
really comes down to is if it's not if
you feel it's not affecting your life
then I would just continue to do what
you're doing but it's something that as
an adult you know when you move out your
parents aren't there to [ __ ] question
your behavior you really have to
I feel be extra tough on yourself like I
drank way too much last year way too
[ __ ] much so I'm glad that I kind of
have it back under control and even now
I probably drink way too much so I'm
trying to look at that type of [ __ ] and
you know it's funny when I when I don't
drink you know I'm more apt to take a
hit of weed because I'm just used to
having a little bit of a buzz every
couple of days so then I that always
whenever I quit drinking then there'll
be like a two-week period that if
somebody has weed hey you want to hit
I'll actually take a hit and I never
smoke weed but then after that then I
then I just you know I just don't like
weed I'm just not into it and then after
like two weeks then I just kind of just
don't do anything and then that's when I
start getting into shape again so
whatever I think you know you sound
pretty level-headed and you never said
you loved her so I would get out of that
that sounds like a [ __ ] you'd really
have to like the amount of baggage she
sounds like she has you know me marrying
a [ __ ] alcoholic give me that just
that that really takes a [ __ ] Saint
to if you're sober sort of I don't know
I don't know why you'd want to put
yourself through that
alright that's their issue to [ __ ]
deal with and you got to be selfish when
you want to find the right person so
there you go
all right older lady wants to bang no
GJ's here's to you mrs. Robinson alright
hey Bill I am a 22 year old senior at
college just outside of Baltimore and
I'm a big fan of your stand up a podcast
well thank you I caught your show when
he came to Baltimore you absolutely
killed it thank you again anyways I
wanted
- I wanted your advice as it relates to
an older [ __ ] lay um so just to give
you a little background last summer
I decided to get in shape I developed a
nice workout routine and subsequently
lost 40 pounds and really built up some
muscle as a result women have been
showing me a lot more showing a lot more
interest in me there you go turned it
around good feel I'm happy for you and I
have definitely had more confidence
with talking to women all right we'll
keep keep going keep going - keep
shooting for the moon talk to those
chicks you think are out of the audio
League see what happens anyways now I've
been using some dating apps and have met
and hooked up with more women than I've
ever have before
not bragging it's just the facts alright
well I hope you using a condom they're
[ __ ] studly
so recently and this may sound weird I
ran across this incredibly attractive
fifty year old woman on one of the
dating apps and liked your profile just
kind of as a joke no you didn't you
weren't attracted to her who gives a
[ __ ]
she is a classic example of a cougar
she's like mrs. Robinson from the
Graduate or that horny [ __ ] from Sex in
the City
who just [ __ ] everybody oh my god yeah
the most one-dimensional character ever
Kym Cottrell's character it's just
[ __ ] with every [ __ ] line it's
like I get it you [ __ ] a lot of guys
does anybody ever just day has to be a
YouTube video where everybody just put
all those lines from the entire [ __ ]
series it's like Miami I used to watch
the thing all the way back when it was
on when we were still living in New York
we were living together in this
apartment I would just be in the other
side of the apartment she'd be watching
it and any time Kim Cottrell's character
would say something I would always be in
the background I would just go cuz she's
a [ __ ] um anyways he says much to my
surprise I matched with her I don't know
what that means she hit you back
basically she's surprisingly sexually
aggressive
it isn't women [ __ ] by their mid-30s
they know what the [ __ ] they want they
don't give a [ __ ] anymore and clearly
wants to [ __ ] me she sends me messages
all the time and talks about how she
likes younger men of course she does
she's want to bang some [ __ ] old
bastard like me she followed me on
snapchat recently and started sending me
nude pictures and [ __ ] he Blake now at
least in my experience young guys always
joke about the prospects of [ __ ] a
cougar all my friends are saying I
should just [ __ ] her but I can't shake
the feeling that there's something
[ __ ] up about it is it weird that
she's over twice my age what are your
thoughts on this bill should I [ __ ] her
or is it a bad idea let me know thanks -
go [ __ ] yourself Oh sir this is going to
be a great lesson for you how old did
you say you were 22 okay I will tell you
this and it took me into my early 40s to
learn this there is no way to ever over
emphasize the importance of listening to
your gut listening to your gut will will
I'm telling you when your gut just tells
you man
this doesn't feel right [ __ ] walk
away walk away every [ __ ] time
okay unless it's like it's something you
know it's some sort of stage fright
thing some sort of anxiety thing that
you have to get over you're not afraid
of [ __ ] women okay now all of a
sudden this woman's coming and this is
[ __ ] feeling that you feeling this
ain't right - just [ __ ] walk walk
walk away okay what kind of a [ __ ] 50
year-old is sending naked pictures -
somebody have to [ __ ] age all right I
know this day of hyper feminism they'll
say that that's actually brave it's this
it's that it's empowering it's [ __ ]
pathetic because all you have to do is
slide it over if a guy was sending dick
pics to a 22 year old chick see what I'm
saying you don't I mean this is like
whatever anyways yeah dude [ __ ] and walk
away that's a you know that's a [ __ ]
train wreck and your gut is telling you
that and you need to just listen to your
gut all right when you go into a job
interview and you
[ __ ] sitting across the person
they're talking to you yeah I'm telling
you beyond just interview you're gonna
get a sense I swear to God I took a
meeting one time with somebody and the
second I met this person I just didn't
like him and there was something about
him they felt sleazy and I got this joke
thief vibe from him and I immediately
stop telling stories and all that [ __ ]
and I ended up going and I just was like
wow I thought I really wanted to meet
that person then I met him and they
weren't what I thought they were going
to be and then I talked to like two or
three people about him they like yeah
that guy's got he's got a [ __ ] rep
for stealing [ __ ] I'm telling you you
got to listen to your gut it will give
them that's how you how you end up not
in the trunk of a serial killers car is
your guts going to tell hey you know I
don't give a [ __ ] if this person has a
flat keep driving you're gonna feel it
you're gonna feel that weird thing so
good feel don't do it all right here we
go all right let's read the last thing
here overrated underrated hey you Brewin
love and [ __ ] Boston Bruin love and [ __ ]
make sure you get it right the original
Bruins not like the UCLA Bruins who came
later overrated Sidney Crosby is the
most overrated [ __ ] I can think of Oh
give me a [ __ ] break dude all right
so he scored a lot of goals against your
team is what I'm guessing anyways he
said I wish this cocksuck [ __ ]
would be held accountable for just one
of the ridiculous [ __ ] antics he
pulls this bag of [ __ ] most recently
jams is sticking to Ryan O'Reilly nuts
from behind you can see in the replay he
waits for the ref to be screened and
assassinates o'reilly future kids he
won't even get a fine [ __ ] him and every
[ __ ] that roots for him uh I understand
that I understand that but you know
Lucci choose to play for us and he was
the king of spearing people in the taint
and the nuts I don't know I would just
you know he also makes the league a lot
of money and superstars have different
rules that's just how it is but I will
tell you this that guy's backhander is
[ __ ] has more power and speed to it
than a lot of guys wrist is in the
league best backhand I've ever seen and
you know
I have to give it up to greatness but
you know yeah he used to whine a lot
when he was younger I think half it was
his pouty lip so it made it look even
worse but uh I know that guy's a stud
man but I understand not liking him
anyways underrated bowling I recently
found out I have a spine problem I spine
problems so I had to quit softball and
flag football the good thing I was at
high school the I was good at
I guess the sport I was good at a lot of
people [ __ ] up this week the sport
the sports I was good at high school in
high school but not that good starter
kit.you left out a couple of words in
that thing buddy
anyways my brother turned me on to
bowling leagues and it's way better than
I ever gave it credit for it's
competitive you win a little money and
if you suck ass you can walk ten feet to
the bar and get lit slash win win thanks
go [ __ ] yourself absolutely Bowlings to
[ __ ] but I will tell you I would
definitely go to a chiropractor and I
would get a great masseuse and maybe
they could work out a lot of your back
stuff because you know if you're going
to go from active [ __ ] to something
inactive like that and add alcohol
you're going to put on weight which is
not going to be good for you
certainly your lower back you'd be
walking around like you're in your third
trimester and you're never given birth
you know what I mean
terminal pregnancy [ __ ] booze in
pizza
alright everybody that is the that is a
podcast for this week all right always
listen to your gut go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday go
Bruins go Celtics go [ __ ] yourselves
you